die korona isolierung die macht uns ja
alle gerade so ein bisschen einsam die
einen weil sie tatsächlich ganz allein
zu hause hocken und höchstens einmal am
tag raus gehen und vielleicht mit einem
freund um den block laufen können die
anderen weil sie mit der familie zu
hause eingesperrt sind und die kids
einem aufs dach steigen und man sich
irgendwann natürlich auf die nerven geht
weil die ganz normalen sozialkontakte
empfehlen das kann alles ziemlich
schwierig werden für uns alle und da
haben wir uns gefragt wie überstehen wir
jetzt diese isolation was können wir
dagegen tun wie können wir uns helfen
und wo ist die perspektive warum es das
vielleicht auch alles so schwierig für
uns und das ganze von wir besprechen mit
einer psychologin und zwar doktor
annegret wolf die ist an der universität
halle
hallo frau wolf vielleicht mal die
persönliche frage am anfang wie geht es
ihnen denn in der isolierung
na ja ich bin auch ein bisschen
angespannt auf jeden fall aber ich
versuche so wie wir es jetzt
letztendlich machen mit anderen leuten
zu kommunizieren freunde anzurufen mit
meiner mama zu telefonieren und vor
allem auch nicht mal ein bisschen
abzulenken und nicht immer nur
nachrichten über das corona virus zu
lesen und zu hören
sie sind ja ziemlich viel gefragt hilft
dass das dass sie viel darüber sprechen
können oder geht es einfach immer auf
die nerven
naja um ehrlich zu sein irgendwann
stresst einen das thema natürlich schon
weil man da ja auch in gewisse tiefen
geht wo man vielleicht als leider auch
gar nicht hinkommt aber es hilft schon
darüber zu reden und auch zu verstehen
dass wir irgendwie alle in einem boot
sitzen und alle die gleichen
unsicherheiten sorgen und ängste gerade
haben wir sprechen gleich mit ihnen
weiter fragen an unsere psychologin
bitte gerne in die kommentare aber ich
sage schon mal vorweg das haben wir auch
ein vorgespräch mit ihr geklärt wir
können jetzt nicht auf einzelne probleme
eingehen wir können ja keine therapie
gespräche führen dafür werden wir euch
gleich noch die entsprechenden hotlines
nennen wo ihr euch melden könnt weil das
ist ganz wichtig dass wir jetzt hier
nicht ein sorgentelefon sind wir
sprechen über das große ganze danke frau
wolff erstmal bis hierhin wir sprechen
uns gleich weiter
denn wir wollten erst mal gucken wie das
eigentlich ist für profis die das quasi
beruflich machen müssen und da gibt es
ja so einige zum beispiel unseren
deutschen astronauten alexander gerst
der hat sich ja quasi freiwillig mit
mehreren menschen auf engstem raum
begeben und war oben in der raumstation
und das war für ihn auch eine ungewohnte
situation aber er hat sich natürlich
überlegt wie man das am besten macht und
meine kollegin laura wiedeking hat immer
gefragt wie das funktioniert
[Musik]
ob der jetzt haben wir natürlich eine
ähnliche isolations situation wie viele
menschen jetzt hier auf der erde haben
der unterschied ist wir haben natürlich
da oben sehr sehr viel zu tun ja das
heißt der erstmalige freiwillig hin und
werden da nicht von einem virus hin
kommandiert es ist aber dennoch sogar an
sie vollkommen recht also man kann sich
auch auf der raumstation sehr isoliert
fühlen wenn man ja vielleicht ein
bisschen postiert ist wenn irgendwas bei
den experimenten nicht ganz funktioniert
wenn wir draußen sind dann wissen wir ja
ganz klar die optionen die besteht gar
nicht dass wir rausgehen einfach so und
mit unseren freundlichen picknicken
dann kann man das eigentlich einfach
einmal diese entscheidung treffen
akzeptieren und dann wegschieben mental
dann stellt sich die frage gar nicht
mehr gehe ich jetzt raus oder nicht
heißt dass ich hier unten auf der erde
so ein bisschen schwieriger das wichtige
ist dennoch glaube ich dass man die zeit
nutzt dass man diese situation in der
man dann steckt außerdem wurde auch
immer als chance aussieht nicht nur auf
das negative schossen daneben auch die
möglichkeiten sich anschaut die zum
beispiel die sind dass man jede menge
private projekte die man irgendwann seit
wochen und monaten schon mal meter kopf
hat endlich mal fertig bringen kann und
sei es darum die alten wir es mal so
vielen oder die fenster zu putzen
im prinzip wissen wir worauf wir uns
einlassen und das ist schon mal ein
großer mentaler vorteil wenn man weiß ob
er sich nur so und so lange da komme ich
mit klar
[Musik]
wir konnten kommunizieren und das ist
eben das was wir jetzt in dieser
situation auch können wir wissen jetzt
war zu hause aber es ist ja nicht
wirklich social distance singen wie man
in den medien oft liest das ist ja
eigentlich ein sehr unglücklicher
begriff würde ich sagen weil es ja gar
nicht darum geht dass man sich sozial
entfernt von den anderen sondern nur
körperlich sozial kann man das genauso
auf trab gehalten wie auch auf der
raumstation das heißt wir von orbit aus
könnte ich jeden tag mit meiner familie
telefonieren ich hätte e mails und dort
das einige nicht angefühlt als ob ich
sehr weit entfernt war mental und meiner
familie meinen freunden und so halte
dass jedes auge ja und über diesen
themenkomplex was machen wir jetzt
eigentlich mit dieser ganzen einsamkeit
da sprechen wir heute mit psychologin
doktor angeredet wird von der
universität halle wir versuchen eure
fragen zu beantworten aber ich habs
gerade schon mal gesagt bitte erwartet
jetzt keine persönliche sprechstunde für
eure ganz privaten probleme wir reden
eher allgemein frau wolf ganz allgemein
gefragt tatsächlich warum ist isolation
für menschen eigentlich so schwierig
auszuhalten
na ja weil wir soziale wesen sind also
evolutionär gesehen auch wir brauchen
kontakte wir brauchen beziehungen
freunde familie um uns herum auch
tatsächlich nähe um überhaupt
funktionieren zu können uns wohl zu
fühlen das ist einfach ein
grundbedürfnis und gerade bei der
isolation kommt auch häufig dazu dass
wir so ein bisschen sensorisch
deprimiert sind das heißt also dass wir
nicht so viele reize mehr haben wie wenn
wir rausgehen würden oder viel rausgehen
würden oder vielleicht auch einfach an
den arbeitsplatz geben und das sind so
zwei aspekte mit denen können wir
menschen leider nicht so gut umgehen wie
lange halten wir das dann so aus gibt es
erfahrungswerte ich meine die
isolationshaft ist ja nicht umsonst
mittlerweile eine foltermethode die auch
so genannt wird
ja genau das ist das ist auf jeden fall
eine foltermethode
es ist tatsächlich sehr schwierig da
jetzt einen ganz konkreten zeitpunkt zu
sagen weil ich glaube es ist auch klar
dass das ethisch und moralisch nicht
vertretbar ist wenn wir irgendwie
experimente in der art durchführen
würden in der psychologie aber so
befragungen studien weisen darauf hin
auf jeden fall je länger das geht desto
mehr negative auswirkungen hat ist und
tatsächlich reden wir hier von
vielleicht so zwei wochen also jetzt
auch die zeit die sich die meisten in
quarantäne beispielsweise befinden in
denen kann man das noch relativ gut
überstehen aber dann muss man schon ein
paar strategien entwickeln wie man da
nicht in seinem einsamkeit loch eben
reinfeldt das sind dann da so die besten
strategien also wichtig ist auf jeden
fall in kontakt zu halten weil klar wir
können jetzt keine physische nähe
tatsächlich haben oder eben ausüben aber
wir können trotzdem immer noch nähe im
sinne von kommunikation ausüben und wir
haben ja gott sei dank heute wie wir
jetzt auch die technischen mittel um das
zu realisieren also das ist schon mal
der erste schritt ist man merkt ich bin
auch eigentlich nicht alleine auch wenn
ich jetzt vielleicht jemanden nicht
wirklich in real life sehen kann und
weiterhin als auch wichtig dass man
natürlich schon versucht sich den alltag
zu strukturieren also viele feine jetzt
auch so in die gewohnheit rein auf dem
sofa einfach um zu lümmeln und so in den
tag hinein zu leben
das sollte man tatsächlich nicht tun
weil gebrauchen routinen in unserem
alltag an die wir uns irgendwie ein
bisschen greifen können und da hilft es
schon sich fester mahlzeiten zu setzen
oder eben dann auch im klaren zeitpunkt
zu setzen war nicht nachrichten gucken
wann ich meine e mails checken so wie
man ist einen normalen alltag auch tun
würde
aber jetzt fehlt ja so ein bisschen der
druck von außen versprechen wird leicht
mal drüber gegangen schon die erste
frage von kim roxy die oder er wollte
wissen gibt tipps für depressiv
veranlagte menschen also es gibt ja
menschen die haben damit tatsächlich
mehr zu kämpfen als andere was sollten
sie tun also auch hier würde ich
tatsächlich raten ihm auf jeden fall mit
anderen menschen zu kommunizieren von
dem man auch weiß dass eine gewisse ruhe
rein
bringen können und gerade eben auch bei
einer depression wobei natürlich auch
jetzt die frage ist ist es vielleicht
eine depressive verstimmung also so ein
stimmungs tiefen dass wir jetzt alle
vielleicht mal verfallen natürlich auch
versuchen schöne ablenkung zu schaffen
also sich sich was etwas für sich zu tun
letztendlich zum beispiel auch sport zu
treiben dass es schüttet ja auch glücks
botenstoffe aus also wirklich den
inneren schweinehund jetzt mal besiegen
und überwinden gesund essen auch
tatsächlich vergessen auch einige jetzt
in der zeit also wirklich ein bisschen
achtsam mit sich selber umgehen und ja
da einfach dinge tun die einem selber
und das ist tatsächlich was ich auch
gemerkt habe so dass ich auf einmal um
15 uhr merke ich habe noch überhaupt
nichts gegessen heute richtig und damit
mal disziplinieren muss ganz wichtig ist
glaube ich reden haben sie gerade gesagt
wenn man jetzt niemanden hat er einen
anruf vielleicht können wir ja auch
darauf achten dass wir leute anrufen von
dem wir wissen dass die schwierigkeiten
haben
aber wenn wir niemanden habt dann gibt's
das telefonnummer die wollen wir euch
ganz dringend ans herz legen
sie zeigen wir euch jetzt mal das ist
diese telefonnummern der
telefonseelsorge macht vielleicht jetzt
mal ein screenshot wenn er sie nicht
kennt oder google viel noch mal sucht
sie im netz das ist die 0 800 immer und
dann gibt es die 1 110111 oder 1 110222
oder den 0 800 116 123 das kostet kein
geld da sitzen ehrenamtliche seelsorger
die mit euch wirklich über alles reden
solange ihr all stars wie war ihr das
braucht das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig
hier kommt auch zum beispiel gerade eine
frage von reinhard baum bisschen
speziell schon aber das kenne einige
menschen die davon betroffen sind auf
facebook was können schwerbehinderte der
rollstuhl sitzen und zum gefährdeten
personenkreis gehören tun wenn diese
kaum raus kommen und die vom betreuten
wohnen nur einmal oder gar nicht zu
diesem personenkreis hinkommen und nur
telefonieren sms e mail kontakt besteht
damit die decke den nicht runter kommt
das ist ja wirklich kleine
personengruppe aber dies besonders
betroffen ja auf jeden fall also das ist
das ist so eine grundproblematik glaube
wir reden jetzt gerade
sehr viel über über medizinische risiko
in sich risikogruppen was natürlich auch
sinn macht aufgrund der aktuellen lage
aber natürlich gibt es auch in
japanischer hinsicht risikogruppen und
das sind zum beispiel leute mit mit
behinderung oder eben auch leute die
vielleicht älter sind so oder so schon
nicht so viele kontakte haben auf jeden
fall ist es wichtig dass die kontakte
die jetzt noch gehalten werden können
eben entsprechend auch aufrecht erhalten
werden und sei es über e mails über
telefon und gegebenenfalls dann eben
auch versuchen doch nachbarn eben auch
zu akquirieren oder eben
familienangehörige dass die dann doch
eben mal vorbeikommen natürlich den
abstand halten das ist ja das gebot der
stunde aber nichtsdestotrotz kann ja
auch an der tür beispielsweise
kommunikation geführt werden gespräche
geführt werden
und wichtig auch solange es natürlich
die bewegungseinschränkungen auch noch
irgendwie zulässt dass man trotzdem
versucht auch an die frische luft zu
kommen und wenn das einmal die woche ist
auf jeden fall nutzen ganz wichtig oder
vielleicht das fenster einfach mal
aufmachen das ist ja besser als gar
nichts wahrscheinlich nur diese
situation die wir gerade haben ist der
vor allem von ungewissheit geprägt das
löst bei einigen diese hilflosigkeit aus
und dann merke ich immer wieder dass ich
menschen an diesem ort termin so
festhalten so dann ist es vorbei
warum sind denn solche meilensteine so
wichtig auch wenn wir jetzt die völlig
willkürlich gesetzt haben
ich glaube tatsächlich gar nicht dass
das ostern jetzt so willkürlich ist es
ist ja der nächste termin der irgendwie
mit der familie letztendlich gefeiert
werden kann wo alle wieder zusammen
kommen
wo vielleicht eben auch im urlaub
geplant ist und natürlich ist es jetzt
auch eine gewisse zeit wo es auch die
mediziner eben vielleicht sagen naja da
könnte man vielleicht tatsächlich schon
mal wieder ein bisschen lockern deswegen
halten wir uns daran fest
aber unsicherheit damit können wir
menschen tatsächlich nicht unbedingt gut
umgehen bei unsicherheit auch immer eine
gefahr bedeutet und wir brauchen routine
wir brauchen termine wir brauchen
irgendein wissen eine information an der
wir uns festhalten können um endlich
wieder kontrolle zu gewinnen und wenn es
natürlich so ein termin die ostern ist
wo wir eigentlich genau wissen gekommen
wieder zusammen oder wir sollten wieder
zusammenkommen darauf können wir uns
freuen
dann ist es auf jeden fall schon mal
besser als komplett ins leere und in die
zukunft hinein zu stammen ja ich habe
hier ein kommentar der passt ganz gut
dazu weil sie auch gerade angst gesagt
haben auf youtube ich muss immer ganz
kurz suchen
das war von einer frau die selber sagte
sie ist gehört zur risikogruppe das
schalten wir mal kurz hin hatte genau
die musik linde hier war das genau wie
kann man angst mit dem virus in den
griff bekommen ich bin chronisch krank
deshalb gefährdet ich habe angst wenn
ich dass er wisse dass ich dann
vielleicht auch sterben muss also viele
menschen dann tatsächlich ja auch
teilweise panikattacken ich habe ja auch
in der frage von lilo 1989 1 auf
teleskop bekommen das macht man bei
panikattacken gibt es tipps ganz
praktische tipps
es gibt kinder diese sache mit der
papiertüte immer hilft die tatsächlichen
das ist das klingt immer so ein bisschen
banal vielleicht aber tief durchatmen
ist hier wirklich ganz wichtig weil
gerade in stressigen situationen oder
eben wenn man merkt so die die panik
über kommt ein und man kann nicht mehr
klar denken dann vergessen wir
tatsächlich zu atmen richtig und da
hilft es mag kurz innezuhalten ganz
bewusst in den bauch hinein zu atmen
damit letztendlich auch wieder der
körper versorgt wird mit sauerstoff und
auch das gehirn wieder versorgt wird
und dann nimmt das in der regel schon
ein ein wenig auf jeden fall die angst
und die erregung in dieser situation
wenn ich jetzt aber eben zu einer
risikogruppe natürlich auch gehöre dann
dann hilft es natürlich sich an den
schutzmaßnahmen
einhalten sollen also händewaschen den
sozialen kontakt jetzt versuchen also
den physischen kontakt versuchung zu
meiden hilft das natürlich schon wenn
man weiß man kann etwas um sich zu
schützen so einfach erst mal ich hab mir
mal was rausgesucht gerade frau wolff
mir auf meinem bildschirm schalten weil
es gibt da eine eine animated gif was
ich total super finde da für sie können
das auch sehen gerade einfach mal auf in
den suchmaschinen nach brief suchen
und da kommt das und das kann
tatsächlich helfen wenn man einmal ein
rad mit mit der grafik zusammen so
wieder
außerdem man guckt sie ist auch gerne
ans ist ganz hübsch animiert das schicke
ich tatsächlich leuten die mir schreiben
im netz ich hab so panik was mache ich
dann schicke ich immer ihnen dieses gift
ich hoffe das hilft
wir möchten tatsächlich aber auch
nochmal drüber sprechen ist das denn
wirklich die angst vor dem virus was da
passiert weil das ist ja noch relativ
ungeschoren wahrscheinlich dass man
daran stirbt das alter menschen sind
betroffen
da kann vielleicht ein verwandter daran
sterben trotzdem ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit sehr gering wir jetzt
ja mittlerweile auch wissen dass auch
durchaus junge menschen leider sehr
schnell daran erkranken können also
anscheinend sind kinder immer noch die
gruppe die am besten geschützt ist was
natürlich sehr schön ist ja was was
können wir da jetzt endlich tun also
sagen wir mal so die angst vor dem virus
ist es tatsächlich nicht mehr es ist
tatsächlich eher die angst vor der angst
und vor dem was wir jetzt letztendlich
sehen vielleicht auch in den sozialen
medien
wir sehen hamsterkäufe wir sehen
natürlich vielleicht auch dass wir jetzt
eine andere existenzielle ängste haben
wir jetzt mit meinem job weiter wie
kriege ich das mit meinen kindern zu
hause hin und dass das ist mir jetzt
schon diffuse gefühl eigentlich und
weniger die angst vor dem virus
und dazu gehört natürlich auch dass
angst ansteckend ist
also wenn wir merken
das ist evolutionär bedingt wenn wir
merken irgendjemand in unserer
gemeinschaft in unserem umfeld der ist
unruhig der merkt irgendwie gerade da
kommt eine gefahr da kommt eine
bedrohung
dann reagieren wir natürlich damit wir
uns auch selber schützen können das ist
ja auch sehr hilfreich tatsächlich für
für die gemeinschaft und für die gruppe
aber das führt jetzt eben alles dazu
dass ich das auch so verbreitet und
lässt sich das aber auch so auf viele
andere lebensbereiche überträgt ich habe
eine frage die finde ich sehr gut auch
auf youtube von rouven cooper warum
schalten die menschen in krisenzeiten
ihr gehirn aus und reagieren irrational
bzw dummen wie zum beispiel bei
hamsterkäufen
ja ja angst ist ja ist ja grundsätzlich
eine emotion natürlich und das geht ganz
viel in unserem gehirn tatsächlich ab im
limbischen system was sie wollen
es ist immer eine schlechte emotion weil
angst ist immer so negativ belegt genau
genau darauf wollte ich gerade aus angst
ist etwas sehr sehr hilfreiches weil es
natürlich ein signal eigentlich das
eindeutigste signal für uns ist okay
jetzt müssen sie so schnell wie möglich
automatisch reagieren
man muss sich einfach nur mal so frühere
zeiten vorstellen wenn er so ein
säbelzahntiger um die ecke kam und wir
hätten erst mal inne gehalten und so das
problem auf uns wirken lassen dann wäre
das ziemlich kontraproduktiv und solche
sachen wie hamsterkäufe beispielsweise
das ist tatsächlich emotional bedingt
das ist ein evolutionäres erbe und die
idee dahinter ist dass wir durch solche
reaktionen und ich sah keine
hamsterkäufe zum beispiel sind so eine
kampf reaktion das damit dass wir damit
wieder so ein gefühl von kontrolle
gewinnen und da aber natürlich erstmal
unser komplexes problem lösen unser
rationales denken ausgeschaltet ist
werden nur denken überleben überleben
überleben
rebecca fragt ihr auf facebook auch ganz
spannend gibt es bestimmte möglichkeiten
sein zuhause so einzurichten dass man
sich dort wohler fühlt obwohl man dort
so viel ausfahren muss es gibt ja zum
beispiel farben die beruhigend oder
angenehm wirken sollen also was wo ist
das problem aufkommen wir können nicht
mehr im baumarkt und in den laden neu
streichen aber gibt es da vielleicht
irgendwie noch eine idee wie man das
kurzfristig umgestalten kann
also vielen menschen hilft ist
tatsächlich schon mir persönlich auch
muss ich gestehen wenn man auf jeden
fall ordnung hält also wenn man nicht in
das kreative chaos jetzt irgendwie
verfehlt und seinen schreibtisch
komplett superlight mit allem möglichen
zeug tatsächlich so ein bisschen
aufräumen bisschen sauber kalt
sauberkeit das wirkt sich tatsächlich
positiv nicht nur auf unser gehirn
sondern auch auf unseren körper aus so
dass wir uns auch gesunder und wohler
fühlen das ist auch nachgewiesen durch
studien also das ist schon mal so ein
erster tipp tatsächlich und ansonsten
was man halt zur verfügung hat
vielleicht doch irgendwie versuchen
fotos auszudrucken von freunden von
familie die sich irgendwo hin zu hängen
an den kühlschrank zu pinnen dass man da
auch so erinnerungen hat letztendlich
also auf woran man sich festhalten kann
letztendlich kommen wir vielleicht mal
zum zu der generellen frage wie man
jetzt seinen alltag den griff kriegt sie
haben schon gesagt man sollte
strukturieren mal gucken dass man seine
seiner gewohnheiten beibehält bei viele
haben ja genau deswegen ein problem
gerade woran liegt denn das dass wenn
auf einmal dieser diese äußere druck
apfel dass wir sehen uns zusammenfallen
und zur couch potato werden
ja genau weil eben der äußere druck
tatsächlich wegfällt
wir menschen sind so wiederholungstäter
wir brauchen eben auch routinen an denen
wir uns irgendwie festhalten können um
eben das gefühl zu haben auch in zeiten
von unsicherheit wie jetzt vielleicht
die kontrolle beizubehalten und da
helfen uns immer so wir nennen das
externe zeitgeber tatsächlich also so
was wie wann putzig mediziner waren
frühstücke ich vielleicht auf dem weg
zur arbeit dass man sich den kaffee holt
oder alles solche sachen gehören
tatsächlich dazu die brechen jetzt weg
das ist richtig aber genau deswegen ist
es wichtig dass man sich jetzt versucht
neue routinen zu schaffen die dann in
der regel auch in so einer ausnahme
situation relativ schnell etabliert
werden können und wie gesagt ich finde
es dann durchaus hilfreich wenn man sich
trotzdem irgendwie kleine aufgaben
kleine ziele am tag setzt die man dann
bewältigen möchte aber dass man auch
durchaus mal zeit für sich nehmen eben
auch sachen macht immer gesagt haben
dafür haben wir die zeit gehabt jetzt
haben wir die zeit also buch lesen
vielleicht mein rezept ausprobieren sie
sich auch ein bisschen irgendwie selbst
verwirklichen vielleicht tatsächlich
kann er dieses digitale kommunizieren
dabei helfen und das ist ein ganz schöne
überleitung weil meine kollegin jahre
hoffmann hat mal geguckt wie dieses
digitale da sein was wir ja doch jetzt
alle führen ich möchte gar nicht
überlegen wie das vor 30 jahren gewesen
wäre mit so einer situation jetzt wie
das uns helfen kann und sie hat zwei
schöne beispiele für uns gesammelt
cordelia startet im moment jeden morgen
um 9 ein live-video kleines gespräch mit
einer anderen person aus dem homeoffice
dann heißt es für alle arbeiten werden
zusammen arbeiten ihr ziel ein working
in zeiten von corona jeder für sich und
doch irgendwie zusammen
ich habe festgestellt dass es ganz viele
menschen jetzt schwer fällt menschen die
sich hier zu akklimatisieren und zu
preisen zu lernen sich selbst zu
strukturieren und dass sie quasi sich
freuen wenn sie nicht nur zur bekommen
das uns menschen jetzt auch gerade im
team empfehlen daher in dieser hinsicht
das ist kollegin dass sich
arbeitskollegen über videotext gemeinsam
aneinander orientieren können diese
austauschen können auch durch gemeinsame
sorgen und einstellungen andauernde
miteinander wiederholen bestätigen oder
sich sich sicherheit denn uns fehlen
diese routinen und rituale die sonst im
alltäglichen im realen leben stattfinden
setzen
und darauf kommt es gerade besonders an
das sieht auch luisa so jeden abend
spricht die in pflanzen in ihrem live
stream gegen einsamkeit mit
verschiedenen gesprächspartnerinnen bis
zu 40.000 leute schauen dabei zu
kommentieren stellen fragen die ihr und
ihrer community hilft es sie ist ja so
ein gefühl von zusammenhalten das sind
viele menschen gerade zur selben zeit am
selben ort zwar digital
aber man kann sich ja trotzdem
austauschen und irgendwie ist man dann
doch nicht allein und das ist so das
schöne daran denke ich mit einem guten
gefühl raus aber wie gesagt das kann
das ersetzt nicht diese körperliche nähe
und diese offline beziehung die man zu
menschen hat sein ist eigentlich so
kleines trostpflaster gerade momentan
digital gemeinsam einsam eine sachen die
zumindest vorübergehend für viele
funktioniert tja was tun gegen isolation
die wir gerade alle erleben müssen das
besprechen wir heute den livestream mit
der psychologin barroso angeht wolf von
der universität halle so jetzt haben wir
gerade gesehen
digital vielleicht aber das kannst du
jetzt tatsächlich was wo man sich daran
festhalten kann oder eines doch nur ein
lahmer ersatz
ich glaube das ist vor allem auch der
einzige satz den wir jetzt eben gerade
haben um wirklich auch viele menschen zu
erreichen und die leute werden ja auch
sehr kreativ tatsächlich also wenn ich
so die videos mir angucke aus italien
oder spanien natürlich auch aus
deutschland wo die leute auf den balkon
stehen und gemeinsam singen gemeinsam
sport machen
das sind natürlich auch möglichkeiten
aber gerade jetzt um kontakte zu pflegen
und vielleicht eben auch mit leuten in
kontakt zu bleiben die ist jetzt auch
wirklich trinken notwendig haben
vielleicht eben oma oder opa da ist
sowas wie facetime skype telefonieren
oder auch gleich mal ganz klassischen
brief schreiben und in den postkasten
werfen sind tatsächlich sehr hilft
reich und man muss aber auch sagen wir
sind ja natürlich es wird jetzt immer
von der regierung sagt kontaktverbot ja
wir sollten noch zu zweit raus gehen
also in den meisten bundesländern ist es
jedenfalls so aber im grunde ist es noch
immer auf distanz ging das heißt wir
können noch raus wir können auch
durchaus mit der familie raus und das
sollte man eben auch durchaus noch
nutzen aber eben abstand bewahren
da passt zu was sie gerade gesagt haben
alte menschen also leiden teilweise
besonders darunter ein kommentar von
informa auf youtube jetzt kann sich
mensch vielleicht mal die
lebenssituation von alten menschen
hineinversetzen viele alte haben ja
nicht die möglichkeit wie ihr internet
zu teile kontakte zu pflegen ist das
jetzt vielleicht auch tatsächlich die
chance dass wir als gesellschaft das
begreifen dass wir doch eine ganze menge
leute haben die den ganzen tag ständig
isoliert sind und gar nicht raus können
nicht nur alter sondern auch chronisch
kranke also tatsächlich sagen wir ein in
der wissenschaft auch dass einsamkeit
wirklich eine volkskrankheit
mittlerweile geworden ist und zum
beispiel großbritannien haben sie auch
irgendwie minister für einsamkeit
mittlerweile eingesetzt der das der das
bekämpfen soll
das ist schon ein sehr wichtiges thema
und ich finde diesen perspektivenwechsel
ungemein wichtig dass wir jetzt so als
ja keine ahnung mit 20 mit 30 ja
eigentlich auch im leben stehen immer
raus können dass das wir jetzt natürlich
entbehrungen machen müssen aber jetzt
vielleicht so auf einem level sind auf
den viele menschen tatsächlich so oder
so schon die ganze zeit sind und das
erst mal zu verstehen und da vielleicht
dann eben auch so den tisch zu kriegen
und zu sagen okay vielleicht versuche
ich da doch jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr
anzuklopfen und ich doch ein bisschen
mal mehr um die zu kümmern und wie
gesagt ein klaus am fenster kann man
auch immer noch halten oder mal zum
telefon greifen ich glaube dass es auch
das haben viele ältere menschen
tatsächlich dann eine frage die in ihre
berufsgruppe geht sie sind nicht
psychotherapeutin muss man dazu sagen
aber psychologin 1 von sportlern auch
auf youtube sollen psycho soll für die
psychotherapie lieber video
sprechstunden video sprechstunden
genutzt werden auch wenn die soziale
isolation schon vor corinna 1 krone ein
problem aber sei dies aber hier wirklich
mit dem vorlesen
also brauchen wir widersprechen unten
bei der psychotherapie wäre das nicht
eine möglichkeit ich meine wir haben wir
schon so wenig psychotherapeuten und zu
wenig angebote gibt es da tatsächlich
von den kammern die idee darauf
auszuweichen das dann noch abrechnen zu
können ich weiß dass das manchmal ein
problem ist dass die krankenkassen noch
nur bezahlen wenn man den
psychotherapeuten live gegenüber sitzt
ja das ist tatsächlich eine ganz
kritische frage die wir auch noch immer
heiß diskutieren dass das problem ist es
gibt so ein paar bausteine in der
therapie wirklich die bindung zu einem
einem therapeuten dass man sich auch
wirklich gut versteht dass das man auch
jemanden vertraut das ist etwas was
häufig tatsächlich nur face to face
erfolgen kann
solche video sprechstunden sind finde
ich dann hilfreich wenn man ein
erstgespräch schon mal geführt hat oder
wenn man auf jeden fall den therapeuten
so schon mal gesehen hat und vielleicht
auch schon ein paar sitzungen hatte um
das dann sozusagen aufrecht zu erhalten
auch im alltag man auch vielleicht mal
hilfe sucht also das wird diskutiert
aber jetzt in der aktuellen situation
halte ich es auch tatsächlich für
notwendig beispielsweise jetzt auch
aufgrund der der der infektion leute aus
den ambulanzen entlassen werden und
irgendwie muster natürlich die betreuung
weitergehen aber das ist jetzt eine
sache die letztendlich auch in den
händen der der regierung liegt aber ich
weiß dass wir da stark kämpfen darum ja
da könnte sich also definitiv noch was
tun
jetzt haben wir aber auch die fälle dass
man nicht alleine zu hause hockt sondern
mit seiner familie twenty four seven
zusammen ist eigentlich die menschen die
einem am nächsten sind aber dann auch am
schnellsten auf die nerven gehen können
gerade wenn es mit kindern ist die
natürlich auch beschäftigt werden wollen
wie können wir denn verhindern dass wir
uns gegenseitig auf die nerven gehen
oder ist das quasi unausweichlich
ich glaube das kommt auch tatsächlich
immer so ein bisschen darauf an wieder
zustand vorher war
also wir sorgen jetzt in so einer
situation natürlich sehr sensibel sein
für kommunikation für die bedürfnisse
auch das andere und das fällt vielen
natürlich schwer
also nähe ist jetzt hier eigentlich
genau das was was uns eben näher öfter
wie sie es jetzt auch gerade schon
gesagt haben aber der erste schritt ist
hier finde ich zu verstehen dass wenn
der andere mal sich hochfährt dass das
im grunde nicht wegen mir ist sondern
aufgrund der situation aufgrund der
angespannten selber und da hilft es auch
genauso wie wenn man alleine ist
sozusagen in der wohnung sich strukturen
zu schaffen auch wieder ein gemeinsamer
alltag als auch gemeinsame aktivitäten
einzuplanen und so eben auch wissen wie
das gemeinschaftsgefühl zu fördern aber
konflikte bleiben nicht aus und da ist
es wichtig sich irgendwie
rückzugsmöglichkeiten zu suchen wenn es
irgendwie die die lage möglich macht das
heißt ein raum der dann aber vielleicht
auch für jeden zur verfügung steht der
gerade so ein bisschen sich hoch puffer
mal reingehen kann man vielleicht
einfach für sich mal ein podcast hören
kann oder ein buch lesen weil einfach
sich meine auszeit zu nehmen und das
sollte man aber auch akzeptieren wenn
anderen seite her
jetzt gibt es natürlich das große
problem häusliche gewalt die es eh schon
nicht wirklich sichtbar die wird jetzt
immer unsichtbarer da haben wir auch
einen kommentar eine frage von nochmal
von rebecca roschinski auf facebook was
raten sie menschen die gerade zu hause
gewalt erfahren und im moment keinen
ausweg aus ihrem geliebten albtraum
finden
also das ist ich kann mich gar nicht
hinein versetzen so eine situation das
muss wirklich unglaublich schlimm sein
aber wir wissen dass das betroffene sehr
häufig von selbstzweifeln irgendwie
geprägt sind und dass die sich nicht
öffnen wollen weil sie vielleicht auch
irgendwie denken sie haben selber schuld
an der ganzen sache
ich kann hier an der stelle und möchte
auch wirklich betonen auch wenn man
vielleicht mal was falsch gemacht hat
man in münchen untergebracht hat oder
was auch immer es gibt keinen menschen
das recht gewalt anzuwenden
und wenn das passiert bitte bitte öffnet
euch ruft bei der polizei anrufe bei
entsprechenden beratungsstellen an beim
weißen ring beispielsweise öffnet euch
kommuniziert mit diesen leuten und auch
irgendwie dieser situation gibt es
möglichkeiten sie euch dort
herauszuholen
also da gibt es auch noch mal
hilfsflotte lines bitte einmal im
internet danach suchen wir werden die
auch zum beispiel auf youtube in die
beschreibung reinpacken eine frage habe
ich noch die finde ich hier ganz
interessant hat mit diesem schwierigen
thema nichts zu tun aber trotzdem eine
frage die berechtigtes warum finden dass
familien schwer so lange aufeinander zu
hocken wo sie doch genau den wunsch
hatten eine familie zu sein
das ist es tatsächlich paradox irgendwie
wenn man sich so die wünsche auch so
neujahrswünschen und sowas anguckt von
den deutschen dann ist da immer zeit mit
den liebsten tatsächlich und gesundheit
das ding ist wir haben jetzt leider eben
keine wahlfreiheit wichtig für uns für
uns menschen ist immer wahlfreiheit zu
haben und entscheidung irgendwie
selbstständig eigenständig treffen zu
können und die haben wir jetzt nicht und
wir sind aber leider nicht darauf
vorbereitet wenn die zeit mit anderen
verbringen wollen dann ist das in der
regel geplant zum beispiel urlaub oder
die feiertage obwohl man da auch
manchmal sehr hohe erwartungen hat die
dann nicht erfüllt werden können aber
diese vorbereitungszeit führt jetzt
einfach und wir haben vielleicht nicht
unbedingt gelernt jetzt eine ordentliche
kommunikations oder streitkultur
beispielsweise zu haben oder unseren
alltag gemeinsam zu leben und das muss
man jetzt versuchen irgendwie ein
bisschen und schnell möglichst auf die
beine zu stellen
so jetzt hier noch eine frage die ist
ganz praktisch aber ich glaube viele
viele eltern stellen die sich die frau
wolff von renault auf youtube wie kann
ich meinen kindern umgehen weil die
immer fragen wann hört das alles auf
also der wichtigste schritt ist
tatsächlich auf jeden fall zu
kommunizieren und zu reden
viele eltern haben wahrscheinlich das
bedürfnis die kinder zu schützen und das
ganze dieses ganze drama jetzt von den
weg zu halten aber genau das ist der
falsche weg schon vor allem wenn die
kinder natürlich auch schon danach
fragen man hört das auf und mit bekommen
sie können nicht mehr in die schule oder
vielleicht nicht mal die freunde sehen
dann sollte man das natürlich aufgreifen
und eben auch die die ängste versuchen
zu nehmen und das kann beispielsweise
helfen es kommt immer darauf an wie alt
das kind jetzt letztendlich ist
informationen zu geben und auch aktiv
gemeinsam nach informationen zu suchen
das dann entsprechend eben auch
kindgerecht erklären das ist bei
jüngeren kann man das zum beispiel mit
mit kuscheltieren machen und zu
verstehen zu geben dass irgendwas eine
kuscheltier was vielleicht älter ist
jetzt krank werden kann
das neue kuscheltier also im grunde auch
ein kind mit einem mit einem gesunden
neuen körper das ist vielleicht nicht so
schnell erkrankt und man auch ein
bisschen die angst davor zu nehmen vor
dieser infektion
und dann hilft es aber eben auch
durchaus kommt aber wieder auch auf das
alter eben anders so ein bisschen
spielerisch rang zu gehen und
beispielsweise händewaschen oder eben ja
letztendlich auch so eine hus unis
etikette das zuletzt eben auch so ein
bisschen spielerisch mit umzusetzen
aber es geht immer älter das kind ist
also auch im teenager alter desto
wichtiger ist es eben auch da
transparent zu sein und sein eigenes
verhalten zu beobachten
also wenn man merkt man ist natürlich
selber ängstlich was auch ganz normales
in dieser situation ist es ganz wichtig
trotzdem zu versuchen auch in der
körpersprache die ruhe zu bewahren bei
kindern natürlich total sensibel für
sind wie die eltern reagieren und das
auch als vorbild nehmen
ich würde dann noch die kollegen von
logo empfehlen die erklären jeden tag
natürlich die aktuelle situation
kindgerecht so ungefähr ab dem
grundschulalter und wir haben natürlich
auch tolle videos wo das genau erklärt
wird
frau doktor wohl vielen dank für ihre
zeit und für ihre ganzen antworten und
für ihre praktischen tipps ich hoffe wir
konnten euch damit helfen danke für eure
fragen und kommentare alle haben wir
nicht geschafft aber ich glaube doch
ziemlich viel
also versucht die nerven zu behalten
ruft leute an kommuniziert geht raus
bewegt euch gebt eurem alltag struktur
das sind so die wichtigsten tipps nicht
jetzt mitgenommen habe aus dem gespräch
mit ihnen frau dr wolff und natürlich
guckt weiter unsere livestreams diesem
sinne macht's gut bis zum nächsten mal
ach so sorry einen hinweis noch gar
nicht richtig ganz vergessen um die live
streams zu gucken kann sich natürlich
unsere zdf oder app benutzen die ist
ganz neu seit gestern haben wir die
aktualisiert und aufgeräumt und die
sieht jetzt wirklich sehr schick und
schnecke aus jetzt findet dort
themenspecials er findet dort stories
findet natürlich die live streams und
alle aktuellen nachrichten und
nachrichtensendungen aus unserer
redaktion also jetzt wisst ihr was wird
abends zu tun hat einmal aktualisieren
oder euch das erste mal runter laden so
und jetzt sage ich aber für heute
erstmal und tschüss und wenn euch das
gespräch gefallen hat wir haben hier
noch eins mit einem virologen der viele
fragen zum corona virus beantwortet zum
beispiel warum das eben nicht wie eine
grippe ist oder hier unten gibt es einen
grafik video über den ursprung des
corona virus und natürlich könnt ihr
euch hier durch unsere playlist fühlen
[Musik]